the jurogan experience we were ramadi
it was the worst place i've ever been
after afghanistan
went to iraq excuse me anbar province
chris kyle was there that's when he got
there so let's explain to people the
people don't even
know this after that movie what the
events that happened in the movie lone
survivor you re
you went back yeah i'm still in yeah you
went back you took
more tours right and and the last one we
went on was in
uh in anbar province in ramadi iraq is i
was there 0.607
i relieved or ripped out is what we say
uh jocko splatoon which is
jocko chris kyle and those guys and it
was hell
i mean it was the last stand for all it
was like when we was like hey let's
fight
sleeping in our body armor i mean i went
out there we took 18 men
and 14 of them got wounded i didn't lose
i didn't lose one guy the day before we
were redeploying one of my i had two
point men
they like they run the platoon out and
we're doing operations
i'll never i remember i mean sheldon
burger
uh i miss you bro and then another a
firefighter
named that's lame starting man bro i
miss you
he was walking outside the tent and a
round came over from outside and hit him
in the ribs
and he was sitting next to one of the
walls or next to a dumpster and one of
our buddies comes walking i was like
what's wrong with he's like man i think
somebody hit me with a rock
and you're getting shot the x-ray is
awesome it's literally his spine and
then you see the 762 round
right in front of it they can't pull it
out it's been encapsulated it just has
to sit there
he's fine now but there was a gunfight
going outside the wall and it'd come
over
and hit him so the day before we were
coming back he got hit
and then the other one shellenberger i
remember he
he we got back and we they had separated
us and he went to a different team it's
sdvs i know
you're familiar with with our
submersible system yeah
and two months or so later maybe it
might have been a little bit of a more
he died underneath an aircraft carrier
doing a dive so the darkest place on the
planet is underneath an aircraft carrier
at night
it's a modern marvel six 000 people in
airwing it's a floating city
if you it's it's unbelievable how it
even
holds in water yeah and a lot of the
training
all of our training is is twice as
dangerous as real life we make it that
way on purpose that's why more seals die
in combat
or in training than they do in combat
usually when you see seals dying in
combat there's a bunch of us
i mean we we get hit with us it was 19
extortion was 31
and it just kind of it's just the way we
are
but coming out of
afghanistan and then go and then rolling
into iraq
i remember seeing jocko and he was just
he had his war face on
so he didn't talk to me choco wakes up
with his war face on no but i mean
imagine like when he's got permission to
jack you up yes
you know what i mean jocko he's gonna
jack you up right like he'd go out and
raise an american flag out in the middle
of the day just to start just to get
some
get it going he's a real deal
so when we found out we were going out
there i was like yeah but then in my
head i was apprehensive because i just
had my ass kicked real bad
and going back i i mean i had to go back
out here in texas man if you get your
butt whipped you go back in for more
when you get healed up did you feel that
way yeah i had to
immediately immediately i mean look at
the fraternity i'm in
and they never they never looked down on
me
because we went through buds together
bud stands for basic underwater
demolition seal training but it also
means if you take
everything away from us we're still buds
because we survived in hell
and uh when we went back out there
matter of fact the first gun fight i
ever got in
i remember taking a knee and kind of
sitting there going what in the hell am
i doing
here i mean it hadn't even been a year
i couldn't even i could barely walk
really
that's a whole different story
altogether but um
we we anyways we got out of there and i
remember we got back to the bay i'll
tell you the story we got back to the
bait some of my new guys walked up to me
it was their first gun fight and they're
like hey i was checking i was like hey
how are you guys doing you good i know
you you got into it you did what you
were supposed to do well done
and and they were like well you know i
was freaking out when the gunfire
started but then i looked up you were
you were calm and cool and you looked
back at us and you looked forward and
you looked back and kind of made a call
when we got out of there
it was smooth i was like keep thinking
that brother because when i when that
gunfire started i took that knee i was
like what the hell i mean i
i was it was just like that first fight
like when you start getting beaten up
again
and then you realize like wait a minute
i'm a fighter and then i was like okay
well let's go
and then i stood up and made the call
but there are
in any situation you go into there's
going to be that kind of hesitation
i i hear people all the time like man
i've been training so long for this but
i still have the fear
and i was like well that's different
that's anxiousness it runs off the same
gland
fear and anxiousness of your adrenals so
in the beginning you have fear because
you're not trained
but then as you train then it becomes
anxious so when that first punch is
thrown that first bullet flies it's like
oh
let's go there's it's a switch it has to
be that way
you don't want to walk around and gauge
the whole time there has to be a trigger
also you can't be calm
you can't just be calm about it you you
that uncomfortable feeling right whether
it's a fight
or what you've gone through it's it's
you can't be comfortable so the
difference in the ring and then a gun
fight is that you have to talk
like you're not talking to the dude
you're beating up like hey dude watch
this punt
so with us when it goes down you're
gonna fight you're like okay we need to
move this way and that's the
while we train like that and in that
fight you got to learn how to
communicate and that's what kind of
slows you down
and it's we do it so much so here's the
difference between the seals and
everybody else
in our training kind of one of the
things is is in the beginning they wear
us out all day for weeks on end
and they tire us out keep us up and then
they start training us then you get your
pistol
so you're completely exhausted and when
you learn like that it's muscle memory
so when we get engaged our enemy will
start attacking us and then they'll like
i'm wearing them down
and then they think that's a good thing
it's not it's actually a bad thing
because that's when we start to come up
and that's that's that's the separation
our in our training as they've switched
it
don't you think that that's a lesson
that people can
that if you can apply that to your life
that you're anything good that you're
going to do is going to make you
uncomfortable
anything difficult all of it whether
even
like when you have a child like the
birth of a child it's uncomfortable it's
a weird moment
whether you try a new thing in life
where you move to a new place where you
when the you any any new business
venture you end to
enter into everything you do that's
difficult is going to make you
uncomfortable
and that's the only way to get ahead
that's it but the most extreme
version of it that we can all learn from
is war
the most extreme version of is when the
the consequences
are your your existence you don't
you don't exist anymore if you fail
it's only uncomfortable because you
haven't been in it
everything's like that getting dressed
in the morning doing everything i mean
it's the same thing
imagine you have the capability of being
trained in any scenario it's whether or
not you want to
get in you want all of it all of them
everything makes you uncomfortable
that's new yeah so don't look at it as
uncomfortable
right that's exciting yeah exciting the
fear and everything like what
right it's exciting somebody told you
that you were supposed to
my mother had breast cancer here
recently
bad and uh she had to go get the
surgery and a matriarchal family so when
mom's sick
melanie has to take care of all that i'm
kind of uh when it comes to her whatever
i'm just i'm weak but she recovered with
me
so when i got her home i was like mom
check it out pain is pain
when we go down in the gym and i'll work
out chest as hard as i can
then that night and the next day i'm a
two-day guy so the pain feels like my
chest is being ripped out
i feel like sometimes i work out so hard
and i bleed and i puke that
i'm being torn apart i love it because i
know right after i get done with that
i'm going to be stronger
because i don't get battle weekend i get
battle hardened
period i've had the bones knocked out of
me on the ground just crying
but i knew that that was just sharpening
me
i was like here's what's gonna happen
we're gonna go and put you under the
knife you'll wake up the next morning
you'll be sore
and you're gonna lay up for a week just
like we were in the gym and your chest
is sore
one week later she whipped it like the
flu she was ready to leave she's like
i'm tired of being around you boy again
i mean my mom is something she's she's
something that's awesome
but pain is a matter of perspective of
the person going through it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience